avec nous maintenant pierre fortin
professeur émérite de sciences
économiques à l'uqam pierre fortin
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez publié en 2013
une étude qui montrait que les garderies
à tarif réduit avait permis à 70 mille
femmes d'accéder au marché du travail
en une seule année jusqu'à quel point le
système de garderies du québec a eu un
effet comme ça sur le taux de
participation des femmes au marché du
travail au fil du temps
oui
j'étais avec des collègues de
l'université de sherbrooke on a ramassé
les résultats de la littérature de
recherche sur la question
qui provenait à la fois de l'uqam mais
aussi de la colombie-britannique
de kingston en ontario de baston et
mighty
jazzy toronto et il y avait unanimité
sur l'impact des garderies à 5 dollars à
l'époque sur le taux d'activité féminin
et on a trouvé
simplement à mon sens littéral soudan on
a montré la cohérence des résultats est
calculé qu'il y avait 70 mille femmes à
peu près de pullulent sur la marché du
travail au québec en 2008 qui aurait eu
sa
le programme des garderies du québec
ainsi que l'on est à on est à 70 milles
à ce moment là mais depuis ce temps là
est ce que le taux de participation des
femmes a continué d'augmenter
oui aujourd'hui
personnellement je pour estimer à peu
près un an autour de cent mille femmes
de plus sur le marché du travail à cause
du régime qui quand vous savez à partir
de 2009 s'est vu ajouter un composantes
secteur privé où on a des garderies
privées à but lucratif
plein tarif qui sont ajoutés aux lieux
continuation de l'augmentation des dés
de nombre de femmes sur le marché du
travail à cause la conciliation
travail-famille que ça apporte et on est
à peu près rendus autour de cent mille
aujourd'hui évidemment la continuation
après 2008 a été plus lente parce que
les garderies privées ça fait augmenter
plus lentement le taux d'activité mais
on en est là aujourd'hui un niveau
mondial absolument remarquable de 87 %
quand on regarde le graphique là que
vous nous avez fait parvenir où on
compare le québec 87 % le taux
d'activité des femmes de 25 à 54 ans
avec une montée très clair depuis 25 ans
l'ontario est à 80 e les états unis à
76% donc l'écart vous pour vous cet
écart là entre le québec et l'ontario
entre le québec et les états unis c'est
les garderies
c'est surtout les garderies ya peut-être
aussi des éléments de politique
familiale sont joints aux sons comme par
exemple les congés parentaux plus
étendue plus flexible qu'on a au québec
on a eu du soutien aux enfants plus du
soutien fédéral et on a aussi la prime
au travail des choses comme ça donc tout
ça ensemble fait que la politique
familiale du québec oui est généralement
responsables du taux d'activité de 80
pour ça qu'ils auraient augmenté
considérablement depuis le début des
années 2000 je suis allé montrer ce qui
sous-tend la halle berry dans au siège
social de l'état deux ans et les jeunes
notamment sont tombés en bas de leur
chaise quand ils ont vu les chiffres qui
comparait les états unis et les produits
en queue au québec ouais et donc
probablement qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
ailleurs au canada qui sont tombés en
bas de leur chaise également au point
qu'à une proposition en ce moment de
faire un grand système pancanadien mai
mais en retour pierre fortin le parti
conservateur propose un pied dit
d'impôts à la place qui viendraient
couvrir
75% des frais de garderie pour les
ménages à faible revenu qu'est ce que
vous pensez de cette proposition de
monsieur autour mais c'est un set un
régime qui existent aussi présentement
même en partie au québec jusqu'à les
garderies privées au québec
donne
accès aux femmes et un crédit d'impôt de
cette nature lol 75 % pour les femmes et
les moins riches et 26% pour les
familles plus riches et qu'est ce qu'il
faut en penser bien d'un côté l'impact
sur le taux d'actifs défi mené est
beaucoup moins important que celui
des garderies et cpe ou à tarif fixe de
8 $ 5 ans comme ça eu
comme impact lors il ya quelques années
déjà
d'autre part
est-ce que ça va réduire le coût pour
les familles n'ont pas autant que les
cpe parce que par exemple si vous avez
une garderie qui
commande un tarif de 40 dollars bell le
75% payés par le gouvernement a créé dix
dépôts ça donne ça laisse très 10 $ est
payé à la femme etc ce qui est déjà plus
que ce que les cp au québec comme homme
qui est présentement huit dalles en cinq
ans donc le régime proposé par monsieur
o'toole aurait un impact sur le taux
d'activité féminin mais beaucoup moins
important que celui des cpe au québec
est deuxième à
réduire et pour les femmes et les moins
nantis le loto le ter fx d'un parent
enfant par jour mais seulement pour les
femmes et les moins nantis les gens plus
riches évidemment père pourrait payer de
20 à 30 $
par enfant par jour plutôt que 8,2 l'an
50 is bien tient fort thème merci
beaucoup pour ses explications ce soir
au plaisir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit